Walking into a sequel as hotly anticipated
as Deadpool 2 is scary, since the very notion
of a flick that follows up the hyper-successful
original Deadpool raises weighty questions:
Will it be as funny, raunchy, and action-packed?
Can Ryan Reynolds really strike gold twice
as the Merc with a Mouth?
And if we just saw Josh Brolin as Thanos in
Avengers: Infinity War, can we actually enjoy
him as Cable?
"Your time's up, you dumb f---."
Well, that's just lazy writing."
Take a deep breath, Deadpool fans: we now
have answers to your questions.
Ahead of its May 18th release, Deadpool 2
premiered early screenings to critics, who
have wasted no time in revealing their thoughts
about the film that also stars Zazie Beetz
as Domino, Terry Crews as Bedlam, Lewis Tan
as Shatterstar, Morena Baccarin as Vanessa,
Julian Dennison as Russell, Stefan Kapičić
as Colossus, Leslie Uggams as Blind Al, Karan
Soni as Dopinder, Bill Skarsgård as Zeitgeist,
and Rob Delaney as Peter.
And first reactions are promising, proving
that yes, sequels can be as good, or better,
than the original.
ScreenRant news editor Molly Freeman said
she enjoyed the film more than its predecessor,
tweeting,
"So I liked Deadpool 2 more than the first
movie.
I think it’s more ambitious, and it pays
off.
There’s plenty of humor, action & drama,
and the movie balances it well.
Cable & Domino are standouts (I love them
and I can’t wait for X-Force).
Plus there are some FUN surprises."
However, Freeman mentioned that the sequel,
quote, "makes a narrative decision that is
not great."
Of course she didn't spoil it by mentioning
details.
Might she be talking about scandal-embroiled
actor T.J.
Miller, who portrays Weasel in Deadpool 2?
Matt Singer of ScreenCrush had a similar experience
watching the movie, since he "wasn't a huge
fan" of the original film.
He tweeted,
"Slow to start but all the stuff with X-Force
and Cable (and Peter!) works surprisingly
well."
Another critic who really disliked the OG
Deadpool but was impressed by the sequel was
Uproxx's Mike Ryan, who tweeted:
"Deadpool 2 beat me into submission until
I was actually enjoying myself.
Also it features my now favorite post-credit
scene.
I'm still legit shocked that I enjoyed this
movie."
IndieWire's Kate Erbland also mentioned the
mysterious after-movie scene, tweeting,
"Deadpool 2: I'll say this, it earns the hell
out of that R rating.
And the cameos.
And the post-credit scenes."
Indie filmmaker Sammy Paul says fans will
want to stay after the credits, and praised
the sequel for managing to be both "subversive
and weirdly sweet" while still having "all
the hilarity and self-awareness of the first
film."
Collider editor-in-chief, Steven Weintraub,
mirrored that sentiment, writing,
"Happy to report Deadpool 2 is a lot of fun
and had me laughing beginning to end.
Stuff after the credits is awesome.
All the people added to the film were perfectly
cast."
CinemaBlend managing director Sean O'Connell
called Deadpool 2 "the perfect sequel", tweeting
that it
"doubles down on everything that fans love
about the original, and fixes some of that
film's issues.
Huge, huge laughs that play the audience like
a fiddle.
[Ryan Reynolds] destroys as Wade.
Great action, fantastic comic nods.
A killer ride!"
But arguably the best and boldest reaction
to Deadpool 2 came from Vox senior reporter
Alex Abad-Santos, who definitively stated:
"Deadpool 2 is better than Infinity War."
Find out for yourself when Deadpool 2 hits
theaters on May 18th.
"It lives up to the hype, plus, plus…
Stop at 2.
You killed it."
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus, check out this other cool stuff we know
you'll love too!